okay so the los angeles dodgers
obviously going for the national league
pennant they're fighting the atlanta
braves i'm a huge fan
i rewrote the lyrics to a 1970s hit song
and named it after dodger superstar
mookie betts well the host of the
dodgers post game radio show played that
song
following la's blowout win over the
braves wednesday night take a listen
i promise nathan tanebaum who's a big
dodger fan living in las vegas
who listens to the show that if the
dodgers won today
i would play his mookie bets parody song
of the old time
spooky song by the atlanta rhythm
section
here it goes
[Music]
first they say whoa this doesn't feel
quite right
and then they stop and say
good night your baseball's kinda crazy
oh my goodness nate you played this for
me here uh
yesterday it's fantastic oh thank you
so let's be clear you wrote the lyrics
rewrote the lyrics correct and who
played the music okay so uh
that's clito escobado uh and a couple of
friends of his
if that name sounds familiar i i kind of
should
he's the uh band leader for jimmy kimmel
the
uh cledo and jimmy kimmel both went to
clark high school back in the 1980s
i wouldn't say i'm a friend of cletos
but i'm an acquaintance of colleedos and
i sent him the lyrics and uh
asked him he said he's a huge dodger fan
that he'd be happy to record that and it
i think it turned out pretty good yeah
that is fantastic that is great
unfortunately the dodgers got their
butts kicked last night by the atlanta
braves and they're now facing an
elimination from the national league
championship series but there's another
game tonight
so sure do you think it was bad luck
that they played this song for the
dodgers i don't know nate do you take
responsibility for this
no no no certainly i mean clayton
kershaw got banged up again last night
it was just
an unfortunate situation something about
him in the playoffs yeah seems like
well hopefully the dodgers will still
make after the world another game let's
go